now fermented foods are traditional  foods every culture in human history has  included fermented foods as a  centerpiece of their diet we gave up our  opportunity to consume these fermented  foods because we were seduced by our  canning and processing and preservatives  and we went towards that type of food  now that's 60 of the American diet and  it's time for us to swing the pendulum  back towards a more traditional  tradition-based diet and in this study  Justin Sonnenberg and Christopher  Gardner from Stanford introduced people  to progressively higher amounts of  fermented foods over the course of weeks  what they discovered is that they  actually were able to increase the  diversity within their gut microbiome  and simultaneously there was a reduction  in inflammation by simply consuming  fermented foods